[Music]
let's say every day you got the stuff
you want you're tired you're hungry you
need to sleep you know whatever passions
are always running in you of course they
are appetites if you didn't have
appetites by the way you wouldn't know
what to do you'd starve yourself to
death so how do you reconcile what you
might want did any moment with what the
best thing is what is the longest
surviving written constitution in human
history students are wonderful those are
the 10 commandments are those
constitutions an agreement between God
and the Hebrews is it worth a shot I
don't think there's a 10 I don't think
they're the 10 contractual provisions no
the Magna Carta is its kind of it's an
element of the British constitution it's
true but the British constitution
doesn't come to be with that it takes
more oh come on you guys got to be able
to answer that question the American
Constitution ha ha we have now named the
elephant in the room this constitution
is the longest surviving thing of its
kind in all of human history and I think
we've reached one right here step 1
it gives effect to consent to
representation step 2 it locates all the
sovereignty in the people not in the
government no one in the government can
say that he or she is acting of his own
will right step 3
it excludes the sovereign from the
ordinary operation of the government
which places a check on the sovereign -
and that is all stated to be in the
interest of
us being ruled by our reason through
discussion James Madison was aware that
reason and speech are the same thing we
should talk things through before we do
them and it should not be our passions
you see just think you guys are all you
students are all busy deciding what
you're going to do with your life I know
that you all have definite ideas about
that and you're ambitious right you
wouldn't be here if you were and so
those are kind of abiding ideas somebody
today at lunch was asking me about how I
came to be here and there was an abiding
purpose I have enthusiasms you know I
like motorcycles I like dogs I like you
know and and some of those I've stuck to
for a long time but other enthusiasms
come and go
whereas larger purposes you can't
achieve them if you don't commit to them
for a very long time and that's reason
talking my wife and I have children you
don't understand it till you do it but
you know our oldest child is 32 now and
she's still our child and we have to be
there for her and those are long-term
purposes right reason speaks to those
passions tend to become and go right and
if it takes at least six or eight years
fully to change the government passions
don't tend to last that long
convictions do reason does and you're
arguing about it all the time all along
the way and that means that Madison says
that these arrangements here this
connection between the people and the
government it gives power to the
government locates ultimate authority in
the people prescribes how the people
must must hold opinions over time to
make them effective this is a set of
arrangements what does this make it
possible for them to do they can
delegate the authority
to more than one place you can give the
legislative power to the Congress in
article 1 of the Constitution you can
give the executive power to the
president in article 2 of the
Constitution they each have their own
relationship with the sovereign people
they are quite equal as regards
Authority you can give all the judicial
power in article 3 to the courts and you
can use article 1 and article 2
institutions to combine to appoint the
judges you can leave most of the power
in the hands of the state and you can
protect that in article 4 of the
Constitution you see the symmetry and
the strength of that all made possible
by this consent and representation is
the sovereign was in the government
whatever part of the government in
Madison rights is over and over in the
Federalist Hamilton to whatever part of
the government the sovereign was in that
would become the dominant part whereas
now we can separate the powers and then
they can be stronger which you need but
still also safe so what that means then
is that the principle of human equality
under the laws of nature and of nature's
God gives rise and all this happens by
the way in about eight lines and the
Declaration of Independence gives rise
to the principle of government by
consent we hold these truths to be
self-evident all men are created equal
and endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights among these
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed that follows
from equality up above under the
authority of the natural law which is
just our perception of what
kind of thing each of us is right
we're not like dogs we're also
interested in enough not like God or the
Angels who I mentioned in the
Declaration of Independence right and so
once you've got that then all of a
sudden you lay the ground for a
government that is grounded in the
people but but the powers are so
arranged so that the better angels of
our nature to quote Lincoln Drive the
government and that the claim by the
founders and the claim by me they
believe the founders believe that this
government because it's in accord with
human nature which is that nature above
the beasts and below God this government
can last a long time in principle as
long as the earth lasts or people asked
and it has lasted a long time through
every kind of crisis it's actually
proved to be terribly difficult to
overcome
whereas constitutions come and go all
the time and the point to know about the
American government is it's kind of like
the way we talk about nature right that
it starts with the seed and the seeds
grow a certain way nature begins with
birth and it grows right but then it has
to come to me in essence and then there
are many essences and that means it has
to become the organization of the whole
physical world and then finally
ultimately of the cosmos right it's a
very to use a pun pregnant turn that
term nature right but these principles
in the American Revolution in the
Declaration of Independence
it's amazing how they give rise even in
the Declaration of Independence itself
to a way of ranging the government so
that we can control it
and it can protect our freedom with
sufficient power to do that very
difficult work that's what it set out to
do and it's amazing how well it's done
[Music]